i've been using the original molecule
air for over a year now
and molecule just came out with the
molecule
air pro that has a lot of improvement so
in this video
we're going to be opening up this new
latest and greatest molecule i'll be
showing you guys
the differences all the upgrades they
have made and kind of given a follow-up
to the original
and all of the benefits and then maybe
some of the downsides that have now
been updated and molecule reached out to
me and wanted to sponsor this video
and have me take a look at the latest
model and this one actually one of the
big selling points is how much air can
move and how much it can
filter now some of you guys may know
that we are building a new home and it's
going to be an open concept kitchen and
main living
space and dining room and i did the math
on that one and it's going to be about
900 to 950 square feet
where this new molecule air pro could do
up to a thousand so it's going to be
perfect
for that room all right right out of the
box we have this nice
bag right here that it comes in and this
thing is definitely
larger i guess it makes sense that it's
so large
because it filters close to twice as
much air in the same amount of time
you can fit much larger spaces at the
top of the box we have this quick
setup instructions here which i'll go
through and show you guys
and we have the user manual let's go
ahead and set this aside
and let's get into the molecule air pro
before we get into the review let's
compare it to the original
molecule as you guys can see the height
is about the same they look
similar overall they both look very nice
in premium compared to most air filters
out there
but the diameter is quite a bit larger
and one of the big changes in the new
pro
and how we can filter so much more air
is the new filtration system
and the fan that's a little bit higher
too so with the original molecule
you lift up like this and then you have
access to
the pre-filter here at the bottom and
then
you can access the pico filter which is
what actually
kills viruses vocs instead of just
trapping them now the new air pro
lift this up this is really heavy wow
the fans actually built
into this piece we can pull out the
filter here
and as you guys can see this is now a
combo filter so
we have the pre-filter on the outside
here it has much more
volume and then the pico filter is on
the inside and then
it will actually light up to activate
the coatings that are on here
molecules pico technology is patented
and it destroys viruses bacterias
mold allergens and chemicals in the air
and that's how molecules stands
out from most of the other air filters
that's what really attracted me
in the first place to the molecules
because they actually look nice in your
house
they're built nicely with aluminum and
nice plastic
both of these use the same exact
technology so they'll both get the job
done
and if you don't need the extra coverage
that the air pro will give you you can
go for the original molecule
or maybe even one of the mini ones so
they have less expensive smaller options
for smaller rooms but with that said
even if you don't have a room that's
you know like we're going to be putting
this one into about a thousand square
feet
you can still have lots of benefits for
example at the quietest setting the air
pro
actually is quieter than the air and
then at its
loudest setting it's also quieter even
though it moves much more
air and on top of that the original air
does have an auto setting
but the newer one has six different fan
speeds and it has two automatic settings
that will actually look at particles in
your air both large ones
medium sized ones and even tiny ones
such as smoke
and it will adjust the speed based on
how much particles are in your air which
is
very nice now recently in spokane we had
horrible horrible smoke in the air the
air quality was above
400 we smelled smoke everywhere i was
getting headaches
when i would be outside and in those
situations it's so nice to have one of
these and we actually have some
friends one of our friends she was
pregnant she was actually going to leave
out of town and go drive to her mom's
and stay there while her husband stayed
and worked
just because of the smoke and so we
actually let her borrow ours
and they were super happy they said the
air was amazing inside of their
little rental house and the molecule did
a fantastic job they had no smoke there
whatsoever there's a few other
differences between the original and the
air pro
first off as you guys can see at the top
here the display is
much larger both are touch screen
displays and you can just
come up and you can get some info with
the larger display it's nicer as well
and we get a lot more information i
really like being able to see
the particulars where it actually shows
up on here
and then of course with both of these
you can actually get the information
that they can give you and you can
adjust both of them using
your smartphone so you don't have to
walk up to it to actually see
and change settings it can be done
really easily on the app and that app
will also remind you
when it's time to change out the filters
and those could be automatically shipped
to your house
a minor difference is that the original
air has this little pre-filter
and that pre-filter needs to be swapped
out every three months and then the main
pico filter is swapped every six months
so you have more swapping going on
as with the air pro that one has an
all-in-one
unit so every once every six months it's
quicker and more simple
easier to swap that out and a big
benefit of that larger pre-filter
around the pico filter is that it's
gonna do a much quicker job at filtering
the ear you don't have to set it to a
higher setting it could be quiet and
still do it much
more quickly i saw some comparisons
against the original one where they
tested
the original molecule against a larger
filter that has a much larger hepa
element
that doesn't destroy things like viruses
and thing and vocs and bacteria and they
just complained about how long it took
and that in a half hour it didn't filter
as much air as the bigger units
that makes sense and with this new one
you have a much larger element
around the pico filter the way that we
use this we keep it plugged in all the
time so we don't just plug it in for a
half hour and leave it
we leave it on on a quiet setting and
then it just
does the job and then the air quality is
great and now let's get into
who should buy a molecule well the first
thing that i want to mention is
if you want to get an air filter that is
going to destroy things and
kill viruses and bacteria and mold
instead of just trapping them
that is a main standout feature in
molecules pico technology is
patented so that right there is a big
deal now the second
big deal i think a lot of reason why a
lot of us like the molecules is
how they look it's a premium product we
have solid aluminum it blends into your
house if you want it to look
nice and look premium it looks great so
not only will filter your air it'll
destroy
um all the things with the pico filter
it will look good while doing so so
that's definitely a standout feature or
most
air filters on the market they do not
look good
now with that it's definitely not a
cheap product it is a premium product
and along with the design and the
ability to destroy viruses and
everything else
you also have the nice touch screen on
the top that's giving you info
you have uh app control so all those
kind of things are built
in and that's also what you get with the
higher price point
the original molecule has done a
fantastic job at our house we definitely
noticed the differences
and then after allergy season was over
and there wasn't a ton of pollen and
everything else in the air
we moved it to our kids bedroom it's
been doing a great job as i mentioned we
shared it with some friends they did a
fantastic job there
and the new air pro it's the same thing
but better in pretty much everywhere
it's quieter better fan speeds
automatic based on the actual particles
that are in your air
you have more info and feedback from it
and it can filter a lot more air in a
much bigger room
and do it quicker as well especially if
you have a smaller sized room it's going
to be able to filter that air much more
often
so if you guys want to get more info on
the new molecule air pro or the older
ones or even the mini ones check out the
link down in the video description
and i want to point out that molecule
didn't tell me what to say
or what not to say other than don't make
any false claims
just give your experience with it which
is what i've done in the previous video
and in this one
um so let me know your thoughts down
below is this a nice upgrade do they add
some features that you're looking for
and i think that's it maybe in the
future a year from now we might do
another follow-up video
thank you guys for watching this has
been max and i'll see you in the next
one
[Music]